the transmission
yes that's right what about uh line two
i i should leave it yes leave it
as is it is the left one yes
left lower one
you know the civilization needs to be
for five minutes so there is no hurry at
all
so we did not hear each other when it
was released now we pressed it again
the transmission so could you please
repeat
we there were to drop out we did not
hear
so what happened when we release
the transmission button the connection
the communication between
ev1 and 2
disappeared so as soon as we pressed it
we started hearing each other again so
you press it again yes that's right
okay so let's leave this configuration
for now
this is mission control houston a view
of the poisk
module on the space facing side of the
russian segment of the international
space station
which is currently flying from northwest
to southeast at an altitude of 259
statute miles over the
northwest pacific ocean everything on
board in great shape
the uh five us os crew members u.s
orbital segment crew members cade rubens
mike hopkins victor glover shannon
walker
suici the
latter four having arrived uh aboard
the uh crew dragon resilience late uh
monday night
to form a seven person crew on board the
orbital outpost
everyone in good shape uh the five us os
crew members currently working
inside uh on a variety of tasks
including uh
utilization as well as transferring
equipment from resilience over to the
international space station meanwhile
rubens uh has completed her work
in support of the
preparation of the cosmonauts on board
expedition 64 commander sergey ryjikov
and flight engineer sergey kud
sverchkov who are inside the poisk
module
conducting a methodical series of
tasks on a checklist to depressurize
the poisk repressurizing it
and then depressurizing it again prior
to opening up the
spacewalk hatch and this the first ever
use of poisk
as an airlock this is the first
tentative step
in the ultimate decommissioning of the
other module on the opposite side of the
russian segment the piers docking
compartment
that has served both as a docking port
and as a
spacewalking airlock since it was
launched in september of 2001
piers next year will be disposed of uh
through
the use of a progress resupply vehicle
uh
a progress will be launched will dock to
piers
and then uh it will be detached from the
earth-facing side of the russian segment
and deorbited
to clear the decks for the launching of
the naoka
multi-purpose laboratory module a huge
22
ton module 43 feet in length 13 and a
half feet in diameter
that will be launched on a proton rocket
from the baikonur cosmodrome to replace
piers
and serve both as a research laboratory
uh as well as a docking port and an
airlock for russian spacewalks of the
difficult
valves should be closed manually by you
sounds good
[Music]
should be closed manually
[Music]
to monitor the pressure copy
15 minutes 45 seconds
we are in the uh very early stages of
today's activities that will
ultimately lead to rishikov and kudz
ferchkoff
floating outside of the poised airlock
to begin their work for the day
once outside they have about five and a
half hours of
spacewalking tasks to complete including
the replacement of the hardware
for a fluid flow regulator
that does just what the name suggests
provides the right regulation of fluids
to flow through the
plumbing of the zarya module of the
international space station
the spacewalk occurring two days shy of
the 22nd anniversary of the launch of
zarya on a proton rocket
from the baikonur cosmodrome is the
first element of the international space
station
they then will make their way to
disconnect
a telemetry antenna called a transit b
antenna that
is connected at the interface between
the zvezda service module
and the piers docking compartment and
reconnect it
to the interface to the poisk module the
first uh
of many many steps in the months ahead
that will lead to the decommissioning
of piers as a spacewalking airlock and a
docking port for arriving russian
vehicles
they will retrieve a bracket
that is housed on the outside of piers
that contains
a series of material science experiments
they'll clean a window on the zvezda
service module
and redirect a thruster impingement
monitoring unit
on the poisk module all part of today's
spacewalk
once it begins the spacewalk not yet
underway
it will begin uh with the initial
opening of the hatch to the poisk module
following this series of activities to
test the integrity
of poisk in terms of holding pressure
both through a depressurization and
repressurization
set of activities
it is 600. so
it is six zero zero we copy
pressure in the hell for the envy
and the power pressure per mv is six
zero one
and please proceed on my go
from now on
and equalize the pressure between
perhaps and fgb
copy
in fgb till the pressures
are equalized so what is the pressure in
fgb right now
for mv
even more to pity
[Music]
unintelligible number two
current pressure is 735
copy that's good we copy 735.
and operator 1 and operator 2 ev1 and
dv2
for the fursuit is 0 17 and 0 18
and 6 8 2 is the pressure
and the time for the desaturate before
the pre-breathe that we have left is
8.40
and what is the could you come again
what's the pressure in mrm2
682 is the pressure in mrm2
you're hearing uh the interpretation of
uh communications between uh
the flight controllers of the russian
mission control center in karl yaff on
the outskirts of moscow
and uh the two cosmonauts sergey
rizhikov and sergey kud
zverchkov who are inside the poisk
module
uh currently uh pre-breathing pure
oxygen as part of the
validation of poisk to be used as an
airlock for russian spacewalks which it
will
today for the first time they
conducted a partial depressurization of
poisk
now pre-breathing pure oxygen they will
open up the hatch to poisk after
completing
the depressurization down to vacuum a
short time from now
inspect the seals around the hatch to
make sure that
they're in good shape before closing the
hatch and doing a partial
re-pressurization prior to
depressurizing
poisk for one final time and opening up
the hatch
to float outside to begin their
spacewalk today
monitoring uh pressures inside the
zvezda service module is nasa flight
engineer kate rubins
who helped the cosmonauts suit up
earlier this morning in their russian
orlan spacesuits
the international space station and its
seven occupants
flying from northwest to southeast
across the pacific ocean
in an orbit inclined 51.6 degrees to
either side of the equator
and somewhere in between seven three
four and seven twenty-five
in fgb the pressure is approximately the
same
pressure is seven three four point five
in electrical control mode copy in work
we are done with the verifying air of
the hour
and the um
and we are ready
okay we are we understand and we have
five minutes left on the timer
just ask
[Music]
[Music]
ev2 all right stand by
we have it as for i have it as prime 2
copy
uh the pump and the fans for ev1
and ev2 are on
the transmitter for ev1 is on
and i confirmed the same for the ev2
[Music]
for the end of the countdown and then
proceed for my go all right we are
standing right for the next three and a
half minutes
timer a minute and a half
and the account started implementing
[Music]
he's um do it on my go we copy
you can put step 12.2 in work
copy is this much here we activate the
injectors
that pressure in work
[Music]
and we're standing by for the five
minute timer
the injector did you start did you get
the timers that are
the countdown all right 29
well for me it's not there [ __ ] uh
and then you would have the counter
there so
yes i do have it all right sergey open
cavity valve and
start depressing mrm2
that's what we have planned please
monitor the pressure
in the module and
also in this
so you would have to have 0.35 0.34
and the suits and 350.
all right is open the current pressure
is five
three zero and uh
pressure is three point nine for me as
the s
all closed uh opened at 14.45 the
current pressure is
[Music]
we're monitoring the pressure drop till
it gets to 350.
no 0 35 0 34.
this is mission control houston if
you're following along
the pre-breathe of pure oxygen by
rizzakov and could
sverchkoff inside the poisk module
airlock
is complete they have resumed the
depressurization of the airlock down to
vacuum
before opening up the eva hatch or the
spacewalk hatch
on the side of poisk that's out of the
view that you just saw in this downlink
video
we are in a handover between satellites
on the tracking and data relay satellite
system at the moment
once the hatch is open they will conduct
an inspection
of the seals around the hatch to make
sure that they are free of any
debris before closing the hatch once
again and conducting a partial
repressurization
of poisk to about 260 millimeters of
mercury
for a final leak check before they open
the hatch one more time
and then we'll float outside to
officially begin
today's spacewalk that will be marked by
uh
a series of tasks including uh the
repositioning of an
antenna from the interface between the
poisk and the zvezda service module to
the poisk module the first step in a
long series of work
that will result in the decommissioning
of the piers docking compartment as an
airlock prior to its disposal next year
valve is open current pressure is
two seven zero
this guy is stable and we are going to
deactivate the injector
in two minutes
so what's the counter one minute 15
seconds
that's good
[Music]
so once you hit that pressure please let
me know
copy will do to do that so you would
have to put the
as the so valve in the position in
position
closed all right in 34 seconds
second what's on the count and what's on
the timer for you
26 26 seconds all right
so once you get 0 0 0
you would be putting the pneumatic valve
in the position below please verify
that
they that they inject injector should be
off
all right counter is at zero uh
rush is 140.
and we are putting the injectors um
in the off position we are getting
correct indicators indications
and the current pressure is 125.
and we're standing by for the
audio signal sure and the pressure in
the suits
for both is 0.38 copy
and we are standing by for
your report regarding orlan interface to
unit
that the pressure is 20 millimeter zero
to um open for eva
what's the pressure the current pressure
is
100
[Music]
all right and then please uh be ready to
put the best
online interface unit in
position for eva
so with the pre-breathe of pure oxygen
having been completed
and uh everything checked out by the
cosmonauts uh
inside the poi scare lock that uh
module's
airlock now being depressurized down to
vacuum
uh prior to the opening of the hatch
that will mark the official start of the
clock
for today's spacewalk by uh rizhikov and
kud
svercikov
thank you
the current pressure is 15 millimeters
we copy and we are standing by when
pressure in mrm2 is going to reach 20
millimeters
and then when you hear uh the uh
interpretation of the conversation
between the russian mission controllers
in karayof and uh the crew inside poisk
the reference to sergey one is to
uh expedition 64 commander sergey
rizhikov
sergey two is could sverchkov
we are at 40.
we got another signal at 320.
we got the signal for both suits
bobby that's good
pressure is 30.
is 20 millimeters and i am putting
orlan into um on the
orlan interface unit in o2
open eva and
stand by till you reach 12 millimeters
and mrm 2 per mb copy and
current thresh is 18 millimeters in mrm
super mv
copy
15 millimeters is the pressure in mrm2
and 0.38 for me okay that's good
pressure in mrm2 is 14 millimeters
once the pressure goes down to 12
millimeters
please
one also afterwards africa is that to
put it also in position
closed we'll go
and the pressure is 12 millimeters i am
closing it
in position closed and um we are
getting
the message the correct message and
what's the pressure in mrm2 currently it
is 11 millimeters
all right please put step 13 in work
that's going to be
mrm2 final leak check
um so please monitor the
pressure in mrm2 for mv
copy and please start say five minutes
in your primer five minute timer has
been started
that's good poppy
the pressure inside the poisk airlock is
approaching vacuum
at which point the hatch uh will be
opened
by uh rizhikov and kud zvertkoff
the first uh in a series of procedures
that will lead to
uh it being opened for a second time
to permit the spacewalk uh to proceed
all part of the validation of
the poisk module to be used for russian
uh spacewalk activity
to ensure that uh the seals around the
hatch to
poisk are clean and can hold pressure
at a variety of different intervals in
the depressurization repressurization
procedures
okay
11 millimeters that's good
uh
okay
again the series of steps you're hearing
uh being relayed
to the two cosmonauts from the russian
flight controllers and carl joff
all part of the checkout of the poisk
modules
airlock seals the hatchway
out into the vacuum of space rizzukov
and kudz sverchkoff are hooked up
inside poisk to life support systems
they will go on internal oral on suit
power
as soon as they are ready to exit the
poi scare lock a short time from now
first the hatch will be open to poisk
that will start the clock running on
today's
spacewalk the 232nd in support of space
station assembly maintenance and
upgrades
they will inspect the seals around the
circumference
of the hatch before closing the hatch
again
and conducting a partial
re-pressurization of the poise catch
and the airlock to about 260 millimeters
of mercury
one final leak check will be performed
before they depressurize a poisk
again down to vacuum and then they'll
open up the hatch
for a second time and float outside to
begin today's space walking working
[Music]
is
foreign
that you're not tired because you will
be working for a long time
so make sure you
work
carefully
lights and cameras
coffee
the next point please look around
make sure that everything is gathered
secured on the rails
i hope
i guess it would be better to come from
that side
it's not really that convenient
you're going to start the tv
procedures cut the hatch tool to open
the hatch and please
put the tab the hatch tab in the
position in the operating position copy
[Music]
myself two tabs are facing each other
and i can see that it is open position
something is in the way uh am i bumping
against each other
with the pre-breathe of pure oxygen
complete and
the russian flight controllers uh happy
with what they're seeing
in terms of the leak checks on the poisk
module airlock
rizakov and kud zvereczkov are checking
all of their tools
and tethers before they get the go-ahead
to open up the hatch that will start the
clock
running on today's spacewalk
the international space station
currently traveling over the south
atlantic
orbiting from southwest to northeast at
an altitude of 260 statute miles
okay so what's it like this yes that's
the excellent is now in the operating
position
install the h2 on the
hatch drive shaft it is installed copy
and i'm ready now we're going to start
the rotation and please monitor
the uh operation of followers
are engaged copy copy all the
wrapped around it
okay
we are going to have a come drop out
okay so we're standing by for aos
yes bob is standing by
okay that's more convenient and
i'm going to reposition myself so it's
more convenient for you as well
[Music]
i guess i will try to move my legs
somewhere
so
supposed to be los right now but we
can still talk the quantities
intermittent so let's wait for
30 seconds all right
all the way
yes
okay the pressure is decreasing
currently is five millimeters
of coffee and please hold it in that
position
okay copy four millimeters
this is the current pressure reading in
the module copy
okay so
on it and it's one millimeter actually
less than one
millimeter okay coffee so you're going
to open the hatch
sure
how are you doing guys
yes
we're opening the hatch
well the hatch is moving a bit but
uh it's coming back to its initial
position so
we'll try to pull it carefully
as much as you can
all right
approximately 20 to 25 degrees almost
open
and i can see it
on my side the hatch seals are all
even and the position on the clock is
nine
o'clock
i do not see anything on the contact
surface
and i have inspected the contact surface
i do not see
any uh pod or anything
and i'm trying to turn around
[Music]
okay let me boot further
down
three o'clock this is what i'm expecting
and i
am expecting the area from 12 o'clock
to one o'clock but let's meet yourself
and up to eight
o'clock interesting here there's
something
there's some a piece of something maybe
a piece of tape but other than that the
rubber steel is clean i do not see any
damage
and let me move down a bit and did you
manage to open the hatch fully okay i
keep
inspecting the seals from three o'clock
to six o'clock
i do not see any damage here
and visually i do not see any damage
and this necessary weekend photography
yes please do so it is necessary then go
ahead and
open the hatchimals
and use the gopro camera
photograph to film the perimeter
no no it's not necessary yes i
think so too so i just need to uh
hold on to something
okay okay i'm holding the hatch and
holding it too
okay okay there it is
recording
so starting from 12 o'clock position
and moving clockwise as much as i can
reach
all right that's excellent like this
this is mission control houston the
hatch to the poisk module
is open for the first time ever
to uh officially begin today's spacewalk
we are
standing by for an official time from
the russian mission control center
in karl yaff outside of moscow
the two cosmonauts who have worked their
way through
all of the pre-breathe procedures and
the depressurization of poisk
up to this point to validate uh the
airlocks integrity are inspecting the
seals
around the circumference of the poisk
airlock hatch so
as soon as we get an official start time
for today's spacewalk we'll pass it
along
but again the hatch is open to poisk the
232nd spacewalk in support of space
station assembly and maintenance
underway
all right poppy
uh
that nothing came out during the opening
all the dust came out
and flight controllers in moscow now
confirming the official start time for
today's spacewalk
9 12 a.m central time 10 12 a.m
eastern time with the opening of the
hatch to the poisk module again
today's official start time for the
space walk by rizzakov and kud
zvertkoff 9 12am central
10 12 a.m eastern time
yes and go ahead and i'm ready i
made space for you here okay here it is
okay stand by
got it
[Music]
the next step here will be uh for
rijakov and kud
zverchkov to close this hatch
once again and repressurize
poisk partially to about 260 millimeters
of mercury
in one final leak check before they open
up the hatch
a second time and then we'll float
outside to begin
their work in the void of space but
again the clock will not
be reset it the clock is moving now on
today's spacewalk and will continue to
tick away
with the start time of 9 12 a.m central
10 12 a.m eastern time
do you see the rollers yeah and they're
moving in
okay so move it all the way to the
is
and i will
260 millimeters when you're ready we
will start
[Music]
your working area and please set up the
cue card
step
[Music]
well if it's ready and set up then
you're going to start
a monitor in case there's two valves
there too and catch their valves are
closed
on easy support panel immembrance
now and i confirmed that led is
on copy i'm starting the stopwatch
yes
35 and pressure gauge reading shows
almost 30. coffee that's good
as well
module pressure is 90.
toothbrush is point 26.
for ev2 one minute is up copy that's
good
is
okay
this is the module pressure and erlang
fashion indicator shows
point 19 for one copy
two minutes
pressure imagine with one second
then we will be monitoring the pressure
during six minutes
and the pressure is 0.1 for easy 1.1 for
ev2 copy
copy
good
the pressure gauges
copy
this
[Music]
290
this is mission control houston the
hatch
again closed to the poisk module and a
partial repressurization of the module
underway by rijakov and kudz ferchkoff
being monitored on the other side of the
poisk
service module interface by nasa flight
engineer kate rubins
once uh a final leak check is conducted
the poisk will be depressurized back
down to vacuum one more time
and the hatch reopened to enable rijakov
and kudz ferchkoff to move
outside to begin their work for the day
the actual start time for the spacewalk
was 9 12 a.m central 10 12 a.m eastern
time
at the point at which the hatch was
opened for the first time
two
the module pressure is almost two
four or to be more uh precise to six
three point five but closer to two 264
copy
is
263.5 same pressure
and could sverchkoff to make sure that
the seals are around the circumference
of the
poisk airlock hatch and the airlock
itself to make sure
pressure is holding the way it should be
is all designed uh to confirm that the
airlock is good to go
for future russian spacewalks as it
begins the process of replacing the
piers docking compartment
as the venue for from which russian
spacewalks will be conducted
until the delivery of the naoka
multipurpose laboratory module next year
which will be installed on the
earth-facing side of the russian segment
of the station after piers is
detached and disposed of in the pacific
ocean
by a visiting progress cargo ship
preliminary mrm uh it's in work
so we are standing by so the current
pressure is 263.5
uh so so it should not be uh
decrease of uh not more than two
millimeters so we are standing by for
that
yes
well this uh work is ongoing uh in
advance of rijakov and could
svercikov floating outside to begin
their eva
work for the day kate rubins has been
monitoring activities uh in the russian
segment of the station she helped
rizzakov and could sverchkoff suit up
earlier this morning
and she will help them out of their
suits later today
when the spacewalk is completed the four
uh astronauts who arrived on monday
night aboard the crew dragon resilience
following its launch on sunday from the
kennedy space center atop a spacex
falcon 9 rocket they're in the process
of conducting scientific experiments
some early utilization
and transferring equipment and flight
data files
from dragon over to the international
space station for their
six-month mission as part of the
expedition 64 crew you see from left to
right
kate rubins victor glover soichi niguchi
sergey rizhikov mike hopkins shannon
walker and sergey kud
zverchkoff
is one
that sounds good copy receipt
proceed monitoring yes we still have 2.5
minutes left
we confirmed
if you want could you please hold this i
will try to tie this up
this
oh
everything is fine
once outside of the poisk airlock
could sverchkoff will be first out
actually
he uh will
once again check the seals around
the airlock hatch to this newly employed
module for russian-based spacewalks
they'll install a protective ring around
the hatchway
uh to make sure that it doesn't incur
any damage from any
micrometeoroid particles during the
course of the
excursion that's expected to last up to
six hours in duration
rizhikov will follow him outside
carrying an airtight container
within which is a brand new piece of
hardware
called a fluid flow regulator
that he and could sverchkoff will
install on the zarya module to replace
an
older unit this piece of hardware
will do just what the name suggests and
regulate the flow of fluids through the
plumbing on the zarya module
the first component ever launched of the
international space station
two days shy of its 22nd anniversary of
that launch
on a proton rocket from the baikonur
cosmodrome in kazakhstan
november 20th 1998.
3.5 is the reading 3.5
sounds good
as you saw in that graphic just a moment
ago uh once outside uh you'll identify
rijakov
he's wearing the oralon suit with the
red stripes as ev1
or extra vehicular crew member number
one the iss commander
for expedition 64. he also will have a
helmet camera
bearing the number 20 that you'll see on
your screen
when we get views through the helmet
cams that
will be worn by the two space walkers
could sverchkoff ev2
will be wearing the orlon suit with the
blue stripes his helmet camera
is number 18. this is the first
spacewalk for both cosmonauts
uh
so we will depress now from mrm2 mrm to
the breath
and in question you
should be open also control
the led on the display and after that
you will have to open the two
manually and
depressed after that
so the injector should not be activated
right
inaudible
depressed valve is open manually
as the so is open i can confirm that
because led is illuminated on the panel
final leak checks of the poisk module
hatch
being conducted before it is
depressurized back down to vacuum one
final time
uh to enable the hatch to be opened uh
allowing rishikoff and kudz
vertkoff to float outside
210
[Music]
will do one nine zero is in the module
zero fifteen for eva one zero fifteen is
for ev2
copy
you know there are some noises
should be in the open position you
should be placed
in the open position
stem in open position
it is in work but we are
standing by for your report on that case
100 millimeters is the module pressure
40 023 is the space expression copy
0 26 inaudible
now please equalize the pressure between
fgb and python okay
in work
or 81. okay 75 is in the module
029 is in the spatial copy
that's just
easy to copy
this
my
heading down to vacuum one more time the
poisk module
is performing as advertised and uh good
spacesuits reported by sergey ryzhikov
and sergey kud
zverchkov when we reach 12 millimeters
we confirmed
unintelligible
it is increasing
divided seven to four
is the current pressure and it is still
increasing
what about fgb pressure kit
it has been equal
so in fgb the current pressure is seven
two three three forty seven three
straight gates
continue to equalize the pressure case
party in work and as you can hear uh the
russian flight controllers through the
interpreter talking to kate rubins in
the russian segment of the international
space station
as she works to equalize pressure
between poisk
and the different modules on the russian
side of the international space station
the precursor uh to poise going down to
vacuum
enabling uh ryzerkoff and kud sverchkoff
to open the hatch of
one final time to begin the process of
moving outside with their tools
for the start of the tasks associated
with today's excursion
[Music]
pressure is 12 millimeters and i'm ready
to close
says that too well
as well if it's going to close there and
there is the two
is closed moscow copy and i'm closing
the estoval
transfer on the
eda panel mrm2 the led should not be
eliminated yes
it is not illuminated party sounds good
it is 11 millimeters actually it's
frustrating
sounds good so please receive
your 14 and you will start defending the
step on my goal
cue card number seven okay
what is mv pressure and also
fgb pressure really
seven three one seven three one
the pressure has been equalized
yes
yes unfortunately they're not caught
very well
should be in the in position of
electrical
control
it is in electrical position one
are you ready to work step 14 of the two
part seven
yes we are
so we are starting transition of this
issue to autonomous towers
the temperature control health should be
the transition to
position six preliminary erlang pull
down
ev1 in position six cosmonauts about to
switch their orlon suits
to internal battery power again a
russian spacewalk measured
from the time of hatch open to hatch
close
unlike a u.s spacewalk that is measured
from battery power
on on us extra vehicular mobility units
in the quest airlock
to airlock repress at the end of the
spacewalk
on the display you should have the
message of po2
prime you know
we cannot copy you moscow
what is the primary bottle auto bottle
pressure
22.5 inaudible
should be in the position
close copy
yes after it is in the closed position
it will have to be tapped
ed1036 for easy ii
can you see po2 primary sure in your on
your display
the primary o2 bottle pressure can you
see it on your display
four one five four ev one and uh
four one inaudible for easy two
and also work with the mli
here yes give them to me
try not to lag on anything
good luck guys thank you so much kate
the um umbilical uh cap
which is
now you will have the goal to egress
very soon
and after that we will continue to
transition to autonomous power after the
height is open
copy and so we should not uh
throw away the cue cards as yet yes
that's the firm keep them close
guys
now we will reopen the hatch we will
open
it once again for the second time
so we will try to position ourselves
comfortably
[Music]
working position
in work
position 19 degrees is the angle of the
hatch
2 19.
now put it on onto the um
so 11 years after its launch to the
international space station the
poisk module now being used as
a spacewalking airlock for the first
time as rijakoff and could
sverchkoff check out their tools and
tethers
about to open up the airlock hatch for a
second time
that will enable them to float outside
to begin their work
the rollers are moving
yourself yes and we are leaving the
hatch to
here yes so the pusher
is being pulled towards us
until has stopped cutting
what about the pressure is it down
completely
is it vacuum now
hold the handle of the pusher
can you do it simultaneously
if you too
the poisk airlock once again open
and we should be seeing rijakov and
could sverchkoff here
any moment rizhikov again will be
wearing the oralon suit with the red
stripes as ev1
could
let me reposition myself
i have to put it back of course there is
a kin
here copy
page two zero one now please
install the protective ring guys copy
and work
installing protective rings
so i am staying here easy too and you
go ahead
inaudible
will there be sufficient length here for
us
well let's see
wait you know just stop doing that
uh i will use it a
so when you install the protective ring
uh please monitor that this port
is not in the um
patch opening
yes we know that so let us do it once
again
this is enough
the lectures are open i
i pressed it down
sure know there is probably
an uh longitude go here
yes i i will test it right now
yes it is secured the
now on
him his power for the suit and that's
going to be
cue card 7 and
15. the cosmonauts have installed that
protective ring around the circumference
of the
poisk airlock hatch that is a common
procedure to make sure it is
pristine for the duration of the
spacewalk
and we should be seeing the two
cosmonauts outside
at any moment now good svertkoff will be
first out of the hatch
followed by rishikov power supply
power and um
right we have everything transmitted
status and for ev1 and evs
just wanted to make sure that you have
uh for ev2 for sergey two uh that
your primary pump plan
what is the u battery
twenty seven point eight
beautiful and plain unintelligible
and then please
deactivate the toe
mode on the um control panel and mrm2
copy and wire
[Music]
please
all right i am putting
suit one in autonomous power
and i'm standing by verifying the light
the led is no longer eliminated
uh is the umbilical still connected it
is
still connected so
[Music]
disconnect the umbilical copy and work
all right electrical umbilical is
disconnected
do you read me well um
we do just a little bit twice
[Music]
we are disconnecting them and then
first you need to deactivate tow
power and then
suit one and two should be put in off
position
in work for the first suit
and the umbilical is has been
disconnected
[Music]
please close out the connectors for the
orlan
suits with the mli
done for the pursuit
and for ev2 and then
one of them
is open uh we will give you a go to
activate
sublimators all right we open
the ev hack and it has been secured
copy
are you ready to go
sm handrail
and what about the sublimators
it's going to be on our go a little bit
later poppy
cheers
are going to be out of orbit all night
in
a few seconds and
you will be able to see well
for sublimators please start with suit
one and then
proceed with it well sergey is only
halfway out
through the hatch what time do we turn
on the sublimators
if you have our first view of sergey
kood sverchkoff
exiting the poisk module airlock
the first time this has been used for a
russian
spacewalk could svercikov and
sergey ryzhikov who will follow him
momentarily both
conducting the first spacewalks of their
careers
we're now 54 minutes into the spacewalk
that began at 9
12 a.m central 10 12 a.m eastern time
with the opening of the hatch to the
poisk module for the first time
after a series of leak checks and
validation
tests on the integrity of the seals
around this
airlock being used for the first time
for an eva
well congratulations you are out
i am outside as well
connected to the handrail and i am
putting my sublimator in the
i'm activating my sublimator
so for ev2 as well right
yes so
yeah oh indicated is in off position
and then temperature control handle
is in position three
we copy
all right ev1
temperature control handle is in
position 6.
and now i'm putting it in position 3.
just give it a few seconds to segregate
the situation
itself
covered up okay we are standing by
flying 260 statute miles over the
pacific ocean
the international space station moving
into an orbital sunrise
moving from northwest to southeast on
this orbit of the earth
sergey could sverchkoff outside of the
poisk airlock
soon to be joined by sergey rizhikov who
will hand him
a uh a package of hardware containing a
new fluid
flow regulator for the zarya module the
first component ever launched
for the international space station 22
years ago
this coming friday
all right then let me unreel it here
all right there we go
[Music]
yes
both cosmonauts now outside uh they're
working with this
so-called airtight container that
includes
the new fluid regulator for the
zarya module that will replace an older
unit that's the first
task on tap for the two cosmonauts
now that they have confirmed the
integrity of the poisk module through a
series of depressurization
and re-pressurization exercises and leak
checks
of all of the hardware for that airlock
in use today for the first time
just be careful
yes
all right i have secured it
i have secured
let me move away a little bit okay
no
i'm getting that
one as far as i understand you're
aggressing
mrm right
that's right and what about the
okay so there is enough space for you
right
okay we'll be standing by for um
sergey one report once
you are out of the mrm
okay the hook is in my pocket there
i'll try and rotate it a little bit
you can put the heat exchanger handle
in the position zero and then
[Music]
i'm holding the container right now so
okay i got it out
it's really not being cooperative
i think my long one
is headed in the same direction as yours
kit to
under your right arm a little bit
closer to the handrail
done
i have secured the adjustable
feather to the handrail or ev1
and
is everything looking good on your side
yes
all right you can guys
a break just orient yourself in regards
to the
modules where to go how to proceed
and we can start the translation on your
goal
we are just as we have planned
we see that
do you have this level central valve
adjustments
well i'm putting the
warm cold handle in position six
do we have your dough right just put the
handle at
zero first please verify temperature
control handle at zero
please verify that you are in mid
position
uh for the switch between warm and cold
and
you have a goat to act to perform the
flow control valve adjustments
done we copy
sounds good
and i'm putting the warm cold switch
and the flow control valve adjustment is
in position
too
all right we are ready for translation
great
at the bottom of your screen with the
backpack and the red stripes is
station commander sergey ryzikov just
above him
is sergey kud zverchkov they have
all of their tools together their suits
are configured properly and they're
about to make their way over to the
zarya module just a few feet away to
start
the replacement of an aging a piece of
hardware called a fluid
flow regulator that enables all of the
plumbing
to operate properly inside the zarya
module
i am catching it here what
the container
okay
do you see my back uh can i sit there
yes i can see it and you fit just fine
okay adjustable
the other is connected to 6013.
all right here's the tip watch out for
the tether
i see it i'm going to move it
is where i have my
feather
okay let me get a little bit closer
can you reach it i should i have to
are you going to move these together for
the
container i will
and our first helmet camera view from
sergey kood sverchkoff the number 18 in
the lower right hand
corner of your screen as he begins uh
the process of
making his way over to the zarya module
he's being joined by sergey ryzhikov
we're still waiting on his helmet camera
to be activated
that will bear the number 20 in the
lower right hand corner
as they will conduct the first of the
tasks for today's spacewalk
that being the replacement of the fluid
flow
regulator for the zarya module
one hour ten minutes into today's
spacewalk that is expected to last
up to six hours here right
yes
don't do it
okay now let's hook to the
handrails and i'm moving as close as
possible to you
okay
monitoring the situation
well this transit bay it should be
below me
yes yes they present day
that's where it should be i'm not
we do see it out on the corner of my
eye well you do not need
as you are translating please make sure
you don't get your um
feathers
tied up
okay i have moved my hoops
and i'm working with a container now
right i am the cured
we're in the process of handing over uh
downlink video communications capability
uh between satellites on the uh tracking
and data relay satellite system
uh sergey uh rizhikov and sergey kud
zverchkov moving
a container over from the poisk airlock
to the zarya module
that contains a brand new fluid
flow device that will improve the flow
of uh hydraulic fluid and other
plumbing components within that module
the first
module ever launched for the
international space station 22 years ago
this coming friday
and a good view of poisk on the
space-facing side of the russian segment
of the station
launched uh on november 10th
11 years ago having served up to this
point as a docking port for visiting
russian vehicles
and today for the first time serving as
a
venue from which a spacewalk is being
conducted
you can see uh rijakov on the left side
of poisk
wearing uh the suit with the red stripes
could sverchkoff
is out of view at this moment and now
ev2 camera off and now camera on
the led is not illuminated
and reba only has one light on
let me try it one more time
okay so two lights
on but the camera led
is not green i
press the button one more time and now
it is illuminated
we copy
[Music]
what lights are we talking about us
lights or
orlan lights us lights well you have a
goal to activate
orlan
lies
and two please verify that the
handle is secured correctly
with a pin
we are
telemetry okay i
had chatted it and it should be in the
correct position
okay we see that it is closed now and
telemetry
did you see whether it was um
coming away um
i did and it wasn't okay now we're
getting the right telemetry
thank you
could you please remove the kids hook
to make sure that i don't have to reach
two times okay yes we'll do it
okay stand by wait
excellent got it it is
now 16 14
and then
okay let's go ahead and try doing that
okay let's do it
during the next uh transfer okay so i'm
holding it
giving it to you
did you cycle the camera okay i didn't
do that i forgot about it because we
also started working on the handle okay
i'll do it now when sergey moves over
here and a good view of uh
the russian segment of the international
space station
uh prominently in the center of the view
the poisk module uh
and on the left of it sergey rizhikov
the space station commander
sergey kud zverchkov next to him
that long pole that you see attached to
the poisk module is the strela boom
strela being the russian word for arrow
a telescoping boom that the cosmonauts
use
to move from one segment of the work
sites
around the russian segment to another on
the far right of your screen the iss
progress 75 cargo ship
attached to the aft port of the zvezda
service module
and will remain attached to that until
the mid-february time frame
i didn't see it when you turned it on i
guess
it blinked
i don't think it's eliminated
no there is no double um
okay so the green one is eliminated
correct yes mine is
and then we can get back to
the camera later okay copy some
securing to the shortcut handrail
okay excellent
61-16
the kid goes there as well i'm holding
it
okay i'm handing it over to you
short one i don't see i don't know it's
number
605 okay yes um
the uh kit hook is also installed on
6016
holding the
so i'm going to inspect this area i
don't think there should be anything in
the way
as far as i remember yes there is
sufficient room
here
cut handrail
moving the kids over here moving along
the handrail
poppy are you
are you holding it i handed it over
i'm going i'm going to move it up just
make sure that it's more convenient for
you
okay
that kid is re-hooked now as well
and then
with translation okay so move closer
then
okay excellent and i can
move it over here okay are you holding
it yes
is it the way
and we're getting the wvs video of
ev2
and also we're getting the view from the
arm
a good view of uh sergey ryuzhikov
working to configure uh equipment
outside of the poisk module airlock
right alongside of him is the uh air
tight container as uh
it is called by the russian specialists
within which
uh a brand new uh fluid flow regulator
uh which will be installed on the zarya
module
shortly
and a helmet camera review from sergey
kud zverchkoff of the work
that he is conducting i'm
moving over copy
do not fresh
the international space station flying
260 miles
over the south atlantic just off the
east coast of argentina
this orbit of the earth carrying the
orbital outpost and its seven crew
members
from southwest to northeast on a track
that will cross the western coast of
africa a short time from now
okay you got it yes
sergey rizhikov is hovering right next
to
the zarya module that's where this fluid
flow regulator
replacement work will be conducted a
short time from now
that module launched on a proton rocket
on november 20th 1998
22 years ago this coming friday the
first element of the international space
station
the kit is secured to the flexible
handrail
and we can see it as well my
lawn teller is also on the
soft sand rail
the third one is installed on the uh
rail
so you're holding it yes it's on
on the second one right yes first now
i'll have to uh hold on to the other
side soft handrail okay can you move
over
i guess i can pre-hook it now and then
you will be translating along the
flexible handrails yes that's what i
thought to do and i'm
monitoring okay so let me
move back a bit to not be on the way
c
body position in the space
because i get swinging back and forth
although i need to make sure that i
don't
mix them up and they're of different
colors
and sparkles okay the hook is now
secured
okay gathered poppy
and let me reach towards the kit
yo i'm holding it
copy happy you're holding it
so let's turn it
let me grab one to the other hand rail
and uh
you're gonna get this from me
because i'll have to move
back 50 degrees okay are you holding it
yes holding it can you try
catching it now okay excellent
and now i have to move over
okay let me do that standby
yes it's quite dusty here
to the queen
i'm translating along a
okay so i guess i will have to
hold on to the flexible or soft tendrils
let me do this i'm at a maximum here and
i'm secured quite well okay
are you holding it yes okay so handing
it over to you
yes
copy
are now installed and i will proceed
with
the kit operations
the kit is now secured and scattered
copy
and i guess it's not clear
moving the kit over
okay that's great
[Music]
look around so this is the panel that we
need
and this is the uh platform
i'm not going to be large
this is mission control houston one hour
33 minutes into
today's spacewalk which also saw the uh
verification of the ability of the poisk
module to support a spacewalk for the
first time a great view here
from an external camera on the
international space station of the two
cosmonauts
sergey rizhikov and sergey kud zverchkov
now working on top of the zarya module
the first element of the international
space station launched 22 years ago
the container in between the two holds a
new fluid flow regulator
that will replace an aging unit
to do just what it implies regulate the
flow of fluids and the plumbing
of the zarya module that essentially
connects the u.s and russian
segments of the us of the international
space station
and a split screen view of the two
helmet cameras
on the cosmonauts
okay well the automatic system is on now
and what we have
is the switches can we use that so as
they're automatically
sergey kud zverchkoff's helmet camera is
on the left
sergey rezhikov's helmet camera on the
right
as they work in tandem to position
themselves for the installation of this
new
uh fluid regulator unit
i start thermal control system the stops
moving to
six to four
no
i guess it would be better to
be here and do one more
and the kids
while the two cosmonauts are working uh
on the first
task of today's spacewalk the
installation of this fluid
regulator unit in the zarya module
it is reported that uh the resilience
crew dragon that carried mike hopkins
victor glover shannon walker and so
ichiniguchi to the international space
station
for its docking late monday night is now
configured for what are known as
quiescent operations steady-state
operations at the international space
station
it automatically docked to the forward
port of the harmony module late monday
night
the four new residents comprising
the addition to the expedition 64 crew
on board
they have spent the day transferring uh
cargo
and flight data files and uh placing a
crew dragon in the proper configuration
for its six-month stay as a part of the
international space station
i'm at my workstation once you're in the
kit position
it's an excellent position right now and
i'm holding it okay
and uh
[Music]
going to install the pressurized
container on
its platform
okay standby and i'll have to
go
position as well okay it's um
convenient now and we'll press c that i
see the antenna here
i'm ready
i'm holding it okay excellent so let me
move closer
to there is no your
numbering here and i will use the color
code two yellow ones on the side of uh
sergey i'm playing to okay coffee
so one four should be on your side and
like that and they're in on my side and
on my side
as well soft dock is confirmed
and please put the latches in closed
position number four is
closed number one is
[Music]
and we're going to do that tv-102 let me
do that
is it more convenient for you
well i guess i can do that with my right
hand
okay so you are doing it right
please make two turns to open every copy
so
uh
so check out the connector for now and
to turn the complete
the connector next to handrail 1360
above the panel so this is the metal uh
connector i can see
save here open now
and guys i have a question
on the we were supposed to
take a break so do we need a break or
should we continue
well uh we can take a break for for one
minute or
we can proceed if we don't need to rush
right okay then please take a break
then and once you're ready we will
proceed
okay the russian flight controllers at
the russian mission control center
outside of moscow
conferring with our two space walkers
sergey rizhikov on the left
sergey kood sverchkov on the right and
that
cylindrical container is the so-called
airtight container housing a replacement
fluid regulator unit that will be
installed in the zarya module
which they are working at that's the
first element of the international space
station launched 22 years ago this
coming friday
the two uh cosmonauts uh successfully
tested
the poisk airlock for use for future
russian spacewalks
that checked out in great shape
the crew is running a few minutes behind
the timeline for the day
uh and a good view now uh from the
helmet camera of sergey ryzekov the
expedition
64 commander as he and kud
zvertkoff prepare to remove this new
replacement of fluid regulator
from the container for its installation
in zarya
and it would be great to see with you
we're now one hour 43 minutes into
today's spacewalk other tasks on the
docket will be
the disconnection of a telemetry antenna
that links the zvezda service module to
the piers docking compartment and its
attachment
to the interface between zvezda and the
poisk module
that begins the lengthy
series of work over the next several
months
to decommission the piers docking
compartment for its uh
removal and disposal via a progress
spacecraft next year that will clear the
earth-facing port of the russian segment
for the installation of the new naoka
mini multi-purpose laboratory module
that will be launched
next year on a proton rocket for its
installation
as a laboratory an airlock and a docking
port all in one
that launch to take place from the
baikonur cosmodrome in kazakhstan a
launch date yet to be determined
okay it is off on my side
no it is still falling okay
i don't want you to push it
here
is it still on well yes let's
make sure that it goes off
okay two minutes are up
and we are ready to continue
the connectors
provide commentary on what you are doing
i can see the connector it is on the
lyrika clip
the metal connector one out of the three
connectors
and do you see any levels labels
on the connector car error
coffee
between the first one then i guess the
next one that's where it's going
okay so go ahead and demate it now with
your goal yes
okay so the keyboard
okay i guess that's the one that we need
yes that's
correct and you're going to go ahead and
demate it
intimidating the cable and i do not see
any pod
or debris copy
and let me secure the panel
the two cosmonauts are now uh removing
uh the new
fluid regulator unit from that container
temporarily stowing it before they begin
to uh
unmate a series of connectors holding
the older
fluid regulator unit in place
that has been there since it the zarya
module was launched 22 years ago
this brand new unit will improve the
flow of fluids
through the plumbing system of the zarya
module
we are now one hour 47 minutes into
today's spacewalk
you know the netherlands is not enough
pursuing the training drills
we had the hand rails on the cover and
here we don't have the schedule so
we will have to switch the others copy
more makes poison which follows fatigue
you can use the uh
adjustable feathers
yes we are working with them
yes you can
re-hook it
yes i can say that thank you
okay the one that connected it on the
container you know you don't have to
demate it you just transfer it move it
can you hold it
yeah i've secured this here
i secured the old the old one
flow regulator
now work with mli yes
i can see that
the mli flap is open
now move this ring clip here
so we are sewing the cable
can
retrieve it it should be in the center
it is more convenient for me here yes go
ahead and close it here
yes it is closed the cable is
uh stowed
we are ready
open uh the handle here
be careful so please look
for any um any drops of moisture
be aware of that okay
yes we will have to move with it later
on yes i'm
ready
there are no drops no moisture
yeah there's a little bit of the
connector is a
there is a little bit of moisture on the
connector i am not looking at the
connector
you should monitor the panel right yes
and ev1
yes one can you use gopro camera
and face fixtures of that
the connectors that are on the module
itself correct
yes
on the unit okay gopro camera is
activated
and i'm uh taking
so the camera is off off now
[Music]
one hour 52 minutes into the spacewalk
uh
rizhikov and could sverchkoff continue
to
demate connectors in the replacement of
a fluid
regulator component on the zarya module
the first
task of today's spacewalk which also
featured the validation of the poiska
module as an airlock
for today's spacewalk and those to be
conducted out of the russian segment in
the future
until the arrival of the naoka
multi-purpose laboratory module to be
launched next year from the baikonur
cosmodrome
in kazakhstan the international space
station is
about to cross the northern coast of
africa over
libya soon to pass over the
mediterranean
and then over greece just south of
athens
you know there is the wire inside the
wire
why it was very hard to pull aside
i am cold in it
it's great
no we will have actually to secure the
new panel
okay so i release the old feather
correct
no we need two points of contact
so to say
yes i have released it here
you know
[Music]
of the container so it is not
in the way for you so which one says
that you're talking about which one is
adjustable
if you want you have an adjustable
feather that you're holding with your
left hand
you can secure it to the air tight cam
container uh handrail
on the upper or on the lateral one
yes i i have secured it there it is a
new one uh
we will have use of it
should be secured with a feather guys
you're in the wrong container and the
second
should be on the wire and on the tether
guys there should be two
points of contact there unintelligible
i am ready to open this cover
[Music]
yes you can open the door
of the airtight container copy in work
one lock is open the other lock is open
so
so one is open
okay it's about to open the door of the
airtight container
unintelligible
yeah let's open the door
it wouldn't but
but the locks are off thread yes
the lock is off the latch is open
well maybe it is the boat is
still holding it on my side
they are free
i suggest to the gay
inaudible
along the perimeter of the door
[Music]
there are a few bolts along the
perimeter split chip
that they all are the little
three
i'm intelligible
guys
yes they are still scrutin
dropped out very soon
guys how do you copy us on the ground
yeah
we copy you loud and clear
so on the door of the airtight
container this is mission control
houston having passed the two hour
one minute mark into uh today's
spacewalk sergey ryzhikov
and sergey could sverchkoff continue
work
to install a replacement fluid regulator
unit on the zarya module of the
international space station
today's spacewalk also uh accomplished
the validation of the poisk
module as an airlock for future russian
spacewalks
through a successful depressurization
repressurization
and leak check on the hatch for the
airlock portion of the poisk module
that leak check you see the series of
steps that were
conducted earlier today the space walk
actually uh getting underway
at 9 12 a.m central time 10 12 a.m
eastern time with the initial opening of
the hatch to poisk
hello
unintelligible
[Music]
you know in your liquid garment
temperature is only 12. so what is the
position of your
temperature controller maybe you should
place it in
position zero or maybe one
one will be better probably
ev2 moscow
exclusive
temperature control switch in the
neutral position and i said
it does not impact anything so let us
leave it as this
[Music]
of your temperature control switch
right now
inaudible
uh